beneath the mother spear deep within the  forest of Maratha ikot days witches  worked there strange magic under the  cover of night when howard and matthew  alton bring you a new or a fantasy  graphic novel a young girl born into a  noble family but also into the hands of  a manipulative coven with darkness as  their cover the witches countered their  dark works and brought forth Tatia but  will table here be theirs to bend to  their will or have they unknowingly  through their own humorous Unleashed  something upon the world which will  finally fracture the delicate balance  that they have tried desperately for  centuries to maintain Tanya but one  exordium  [Music]  now available for pre-sale on IndieGoGo  [Music]